je ne peux pas me déplacer en 2022
sans le calendrier de quart arrière que
je suis comme ça et on me l'a leur
mémoire est chérie tu venir un swing
tuer la longue marche je vais regarder
déjà janvier chien qui préoccupaient
non mais c'est vrai janvier choper gérer
l'effet bria février février je suis un
petit peu occupé aussi un livret mais
février et puis si tu n'es pas ça la
première fois du calme et oui j'ai eu un
reconnaissance et les bastos c'est que
je connais oui c'est vrai enfin sarah
exactement c'est ça je me disais bastos
et donc vous avez eu un invité et ben
écoutez bcbe c'est bien d'inviter
et rentre partout
les fruits un oui à bas il n'ya pas des
fruits merci sur le quadrille à la
raison que le président mais c'est vrai
je fais des gens qui me demandent
parfois sur instagram m'acheter selon la
loi je pars intimes comme dans le
calendrier ya rien
rien
non
c'est vrai que sceptique sur un miroir
connu là
c'est vrai que cette petite chanson
leurs droits bien sûr que la connais je
l'adoré ampleur c'est un amour avocat et
c'est toute l'afrique je connais très
bien bien sûr je connais très bien la
soeur de clarac s'embrassent qui est un
amour toujours dans les bijoux dans
l'est dont il joue oui tout à fait et ou
pas
je connais bah oui j'ai retenu surtout
du tsunami bah oui voilà une façon la
ville et moi la seule marche ça c'est
mars à semmar ce schéma c'est vrai que
marc sebbah c'est sympa moi c'est marx
moi j'aime bien me balader comme ça
c'est juste après ça c'est une
d'ailleurs mais comme on est là on met
des fruits non à nadal
est
ce qu'on l'a contacté le cheval
je les aime beaucoup sa 1000ème et celui
de l'année dernière à verser dans des
passes qui sont fait plaisir
mais c'est quoi la vie le style cette
année c'est très ferme hier non alors
l'idée si vous avez perdu
feria de la danette ou pas dans la
halle et ios et l'année tirs sur la tête
de ma mère y aller comme à ce qu'est ce
que tu nous apprennent alors vous avez
travaillé avec nos pays sont venus à
yoplait sur le calendrier qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est quoi le délire j'adore
mais ça va fumer effectivement s'est
dénudée c'est un peu une métaphore de la
liberté à la liberté le démarrage c'est
un
livre à part les pardonner tous solides
on voit qui allie barbelés me vois que
vous êtes libérés délivré sur la
poitrine c'est magnifique ouais
alors ça
merci le mois de mai
je vais le faire
et donc là le muguet ou sûr mais là
c'est pour savoir
c'est beau voilà et géraldine adore
alors je veux faire toute l'année on
attend qu'on est parti un alors en plus
il ya deux pages par par mois sur le
mois et coupeurs de locomotive
au quai du port de bales moi aussi
je crois que j'ai trouvé moi préféré
pourquoi non pas parce qu'on est en
vacances mais j'aime bien le début du
mois de juin
ça c'est le mois de juin ces essais bout
la chevelure comme flins pour garder la
regarder vraiment la cclat
qui voulait faire un point sur celle à
les parties au bord de la plage elle
s'est assise sur un tronc d'arbre et
regardez ce que ça donne
walt et le bilan s'élèverait des poteaux
oui c'est les points de dépôt
alors le mois de juillet le mois de
juillet j'adore on va faire tout cas
n'ont rien carratier là c'est ça alors
là c'est quoi la tute est parée de ton
lit en fait tu t es barré d'appel
gratuites et cassé et sa libre au
démarrage c'est c'est vrai que j'évoque
le poids la société les religions c'est
un petit peu chargé
là on voit le poids de la religion là
alors le problème
du poids de la société la dawla se
situe avec les gars
là je vois le poids de la société la
saison là on est on sent qu'on est en
hausse chez nous dès le début de pluie
du calendrier
est là là là je sens claque au mois
d'août ça y est vous prenez votre boss
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes libérés délivrés
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que clara a
le centre parfait j'aimerais way avait
le modèle de série c'est aussi un modèle
pour toutes les femmes on y voler des
singes ça se sait depuis très longtemps
les benjamins modèle
partout que madame
de sa paresse et 90 et 100 alors moi
j'ai bu réveil je le dis pour la
dernière bulle gamme g la coupe
parfaitement
sain garçons
[Rires]
n'ont pas les couilles apparemment oui
je confirme
oui bien sûr c'est important et ça va
faire sérieux sans rivaux politiques ah
la la classe elle avait démarré à
château de sable est il dit nous sommes
touchés
voilà c'est très bon là c'est le mois et
donc la liberté c'est le mois d'août a
indiqué alors il ya le mois de septembre
le mois cet homme c'est mon anniversaire
j'ai regardé la rentrée des classes pour
l'anniversaire bon voir votre fou non
adversaire match mais on n'avait pas vu
avant et pour l'anniversaire est bon on
voit la bouffonne et ben ça y est et ben
voilà c'est l'annoncé en contrefaçon je
suis un garçon
discret et élégant bas bien sûr oui mais
moi je la vois moi je la prends moi je
la bois j'ai dit allez je la vois et ça
fait plaisir c'est ton anniversaire
qu'il faut entendre vendredi que pour
toi j'ai pensé à toi je me suis dit
quand tu regardes mais un regard
s'arrête puis le 23 septembre c'est
dingue ça
s'il atteint message a passé en v2 dire
pile poil non mais c'est ça
allait si je trace la médiatrice là au
niveau de la delà de la docherie
est bon là il aura 3 septembre à kiev
tout cas c'est fou que ça c'est fou
direz vous êtes mis d'accord au alors là
les mois d'octobre à l'anniversaire de
mon père ses démons qui va lui offrir
black dial alors eh ben elle est assise
chant elle et elle marche sur un tronc
regarder
un ange
oui alors les enjeux comme ça j'aimerais
bien lié à l'idate
les eaux a dit le représentant nu en
serbie oui bah écoutez bonne foi dans
ses bons jours le mois d'octobre je suis
d'accord sur la salade ça c'est très bon
j'adore on dirait une barbe à papa
lé sens parfait mais là la phase
parfaite oui les brûlures et tous ces
magnifiques mais comment passer bon
c'est moi c'est bon bateau a alors
bergerie le photographe pendant
à dieu bénisse une année il a dû faire
un avis
sergio rizzo
benzema 10 bergerie en bergerie du cari
elle a fait le loup dans la bergerie à
la fin qui fut là pendant ce temps là il
ya des photographes frappé pour la photo
de classe des enfants
[Rires]
dans le chaos et de caramel oui oui je
suis libre ouais moi je vais y aller
balle à la tête il sait que c'est dingue
mais c'est vrai quoi là jamais la
photographe pour mon cabaret way pour le
cabaret c'est quand même olé olé ou sexy
et oui la veille il était en photo de
classe bah tu vois moi ça me change
baquet faut pas qu'il y mélanger
parce que c'est provisoire la barre
[Musique]
des 4 go vide dans l'école a alors oui
oh là j'adore le mois de novembre alors
c'est à dire salle jean pierre foucault
ouanna 23 novembre on aime jean pierre
regarde comment le bien représentés tu
es là entre la dont il annoncé
oui j'adore jamais personne ne prenne
propos comme ça sur lequel oui c'est
incroyable je dis va dire que moi qui
peut perdre une minute sur un calendrier
bah oui mais tu sais car là où tu saches
un truc oui j'ai changé oui c'est vrai
ça s'accorde à 15 ans oui on la
connaissait je peux vous dire s est même
pas ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
à chercher chercher la lumière est elle
à trouver l'interrupteur
[Rires]
oui parce qu'on voudra plus que la
lumière qui retombe sur celle et ils ont
sauté ou pas et n'en ont sauté mais
l'arrêté je suis on est on est on est
quand on est copains comme khallouf